guten morgen herr ullrich ja sagen sie
mir als allererstes wie kann sie sich
erklären dass es überhaupt zu dieser
situation hier in berlin gekommen ist
schönen guten morgen ich glaube dass der
innensenator geisel sieht das ohne
überlin völlig falsch eingeschätzt hat
es kann nicht sein dass das
reichstagsgebäude als symbol unserer
demokratie als unser parlament
schlichtweg nicht geschützt wird
das reiht sich ein in eine kette von
fehleinschätzungen die das land berlin
konsequent aufarbeiten muss
es hat er begonnen mit der sehr
unglücklichen untersagungsverfügung und
setzt sich dann fort über die
polizeitaktik an diesen vergangenen
samstag ich glaube einfach dass das land
berlin die situation nicht im griff hat
und das ist kein gutes signal für die
innere sicherheit
was muss sich also jetzt konkret in der
hauptstadt ein
ja wir brauchen ein größeres bewusstsein
für die entsprechenden demonstrations-
lagen die gebäude der central
verfassungsorgan in deutschland müssen
schlichtweg stärke geschützt werden dazu
brauchen wir eine andere polizeitaktik
und letztlich und das glaube ich fehlt
auch in berlin brauchen wir auch eine
andere kultur
wir brauchen eine kultur der
wertschätzung unserer polizei und wenn
man sich die aussagen auch einiger
führender vertreter anzieht die in
berlin regieren dann fehlt ist ein stück
weit an dieser wertschätzung für unsere
polizei
die polizei muss sich darauf verlassen
können dass in solchen wagen die politik
hinter ihnen steht und nicht ihre ihre
arbeit permanent infrage gestellt also
es muss sich ändern dass wir bei diesen
großen demonstrations- lagen ein anderes
ein besseres und ein konsequenteres
sicherheitskonzept haben zum
sicherheitskonzept normalerweise gibt es
hier eine bannmeile rund um den
reichstag herum damit demonstration gar
nicht erst so nah ran kommen können
warum war das am wochenende jetzt anders
das liegt daran dass es bereits knapp 20
jahren eine gesetzliche
regelungen gibt wonach ein sogenannter
bisher bezirk also bannmeile nur in
sitzungswochen des parlaments existiert
und das parlament in nichts
sitzungswochen eben gerade diesen schutz
nicht hat wir müssen uns nach den
bildern von gestern schon fragen ob wir
diese bannmeile nicht auch für nichts
sitzungswochen brauchen es geht bei dem
reichstagsgebäude beim deutschen
bundestag um das ernst unserer
demokratie es geht um die
volksvertretung die alle deutschen
gleichermaßen repräsentiert und da kann
es nicht sein dass wir solche bilder
hinnehmen müssen das ist ein ganz
schlimmes signal in unserer gesellschaft
aber auch um die welt hinaus das war
eine beschämende und entwürdigende
bilder und die darf es in unserem
eigenen interesse so nicht mehr geben
deswegen müssen wir uns überlegen ob wir
diesen befehl bitte diese dann meine ich
ein stück weit ausdehnen
das in ihren augen auch personelle
konsequenzen geben genauer gefragt nach
innensenator geißel der sich heute wie
bereits erwähnt frage und antwort stehen
muss im abgeordnetenhaus in ihren augen
müsste er jetzt zurücktreten
ich glaube das sehen also geißel die
fragen sehr genau wie antworten muss und
er musste dem akuten haus in berlin aber
auch der öffentlichkeit tatsächlich
seine einschätzungen darlegen beginnend
mit der sehr unglücklich formulierten
verbotsverfügung über seine ziemlich
kuriosen äußerungen zum thema
versammlungsfreiheit bis zum konzept am
vergangenen am vergangenen samstag
ich sag mal so wenn man sich das in der
gesamtschau sieht dann ist er kein
starker innensenator ob er jetzt
zurücktreten müsse oder nicht ich glaube
berlin werde mit einem alle anderen
senator sicherlich besser dran aber das
müssen dann letztlich auch in der
einschätzung die kollegen in berlin
entscheiden